buenos días me llamo steve juan y hoy
voy a hablar en castellano en español
por los que no me conocen yo tengo el
hábito de hacer vídeos sobre todo en
inglés sobre el aprendizaje de idiomas y
me han pedido de hacer vídeos en otros
idiomas idiomas otro que en inglés
lo he hecho en francés y ahora voy a
tratar de hacerlo en español aunque es
un idioma que habló una vez dos veces el
año
bueno para mí lo más importante en el
factor más importante decisiva para
lograr la fluidez en un otro idioma es
la motivación
y hay tres preguntas que son muy muy
indicadores muy decisivas para decidir
si uno
alguien tiene la motivación para lograr
son 3
la primera es
es que puedo yo lograr es muy importante
si no tiene si tú no tienes la confianza
de poder lograr
alcanzar a tu meta no es mejor no
empezar si tú vas a hacer un viaje y no
crees que puede
alcanzar
al destino la destinación
el viaje si vas a
hacer del alpinismo no si tú no crees
que puede alcanzar al cumbre es que no
va a tener éxito entonces es muy
importante que uno tiene está que tenga
esta convicción que puede tener éxito y
yo a la edad de 16 años solamente
hablaba inglés y no tenía esta
experiencia de de convertir en una
persona que habló a otro idioma
yo no tenía esta confianza pero ahora lo
tengo y yo soy persona convencido que
cada persona algunos más rápido algunos
más despacio pero cada persona tiene el
talento
es capaz de convertirse en una persona
que habla otro idioma pero hay que
hacerlo una vez y por eso creo que es
muy importante de como de darse en el
beneficio de la duda como existe en
inglés tu puedes hacerlo seguro segunda
pregunta
funciona ahora es decir el método que
estoy utilizando empleando para aprender
este cual incidió cualquier idioma
este es este método es eficaz 1 si tú no
crees que el método es esta eficaz que
la clase el profesor que el libro que el
método
sea eficaz esto este no va
no funcionará por ti entonces es muy
importante elegir seleccionar un método
en que tú tienes confianza ahora otra
vez la cuestión de confiar de confianza
en el método y si tú no tienes de esta
confianza hay que cambiar yo tengo
confianza en el método que yo siempre
utilizo es de escuchar mucho leer mucho
hacer crecer que crecer mi vocabulario
para poder comprar comprender lo que
dice la mente y después la capacidad de
hablar va se desarrollar naturalmente es
mi método soy convencido que ésta
funciona pero si tú tienes otro método
que te parece mejor en web hay que
utilizarlo pero si tú no crees que el
método va a funcionar para ti hay que
cambiar de método entonces era la
segunda pregunta y la tercera pregunta
es vale la pena
de estudiar idiomas vale la pena porque
cuesta mucho cuesta mucho en no
necesariamente en dinero pero en tiempo
en esfuerzo porque bueno al inicio al
principio
hay contenidos lecciones muy aburridos
aburridas contenidos aburridos pero sin
embargo son difíciles y durante mucho
tiempo va siguiendo aprendiendo palabras
olvidando aprendiendo olvidando y
después cuando empieces a hablar es con
mucha dificultad
pues te cuesta mucho bueno hay que ser
hay que estar convencido que este vale
la pena para mí vale la pena de punto de
visto profesional he utilizado mis
idiomas como chino japonés francés sueco
en mis negocios tengo amigos en muchos
muchos países para prepararme por él
por esta descripción en español porque
casi nunca hablo español habrá todos los
tres años vamos en españa unas dos
semanas unas dos semanas pero he
escuchado escuchado es muy conveniente
ahora en el website audible verbo
audible.com puede descargar audiolibros
en amazon he cumplido el libro
dime quién soy de julia navarro lo he
leído es muy larga es largo
este libro y también he descargado el
audiolibro y también un audiolibros que
se llama breve historia de la guerra
civil y he aprendido mucho un montón de
cosas y hay un poco es refrescado mi
cabeza no pero hablo con errores hablo
con dificultades pero puedo hablar pero
la posibilidad yo tengo libros en
español en chino en alemán y para
prepararme
otros vídeos en otros idiomas
voy a leer voy a escuchar cosas en
japonés es un gran placer es un placer
enorme
tengo mi vecino es chino y de vez en
cuando vamos a cenar juntos se habla
chino
de todos los puntos de vista es cultural
social profesional y también parece que
permite editar la demencia en la gente
la gente mayor
no sé si es verdad o no pero para mí
vale la pena pero esto también cada uno
tiene que decidir por su mismo entonces
tres preguntas primero prima primera
pregunta puedo yo lograr tener éxito
pues está dispuesta es si hay que decir
si aún si no no tenga esta experiencia
hay hay que decir sí segundo está el
método es eficaz si no hay que buscar un
método que sea eficaz y tercera pregunta
vale este la pena bueno este es acaba de
decidir pero si la respuesta a esas tres
preguntas es sí
pues sí soy seguro que cada uno va a
tener éxito bueno
y mucho gusto y hasta hasta luego adiós